ça c'est notre synchro cyclage quelqu'un
peut le prendre oui moi ok ce vendredi
matin pour les 6e du collège le village
de trappes
les cours se faisait dans la nature
l'île des loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines lors a ouvert ses portes pour
se faire faire une mise en beauté
elles le font pour la nature et en même
temps ça les salles et sensibilise
salaires apprend les bonnes habitudes
même pas jeter on leur donne des petits
conseils prendre l'habitude de jeter
dans les poubelles ou mettre dans la
poche en attendant de trouver une
poubelle et des bouteilles d'eau
plus qu'un simple ramassage il s'agit
aussi de les éveiller au tri des déchets
les papiers là là dans la poubelle et
nos esclaves et les bouteilles dans la
pouvait être recyclables on a ramassé
des bouteilles de verre on a ramassé du
du à papier du plastique et mais on a
ramassé des bouchons cela fait trois ans
que le collège organise cette opération
à lille de loisirs avec une poursuite en
classe pour que les bonnes habitudes
s'installent tout les sixièmes participe
tous les ans comme ça à terme le but est
que tous les élèves du collège effet
cette activité pour qu'ils respectent
après au collège aussi les règles de
recyclage en une matinée les jeunes
trappistes ont ramassé 900 litres
d'emballages recyclables 600 litres de
bouteilles en verre et une vingtaine de
sacs de déchets divers
prochaine étape pour les collégiens la
visite d'un centre de recyclage pour
continuer le tri